so yeah if you guys saw on our uh
twitter you saw the our new mascot it's
it's it's this little adorable creature
you want to stay here
yeah we this is the first animal we've
ever had on set yeah
how long how long have you had yes
how long how long have you guys had
cattle for karo we got uh right in the
beginning pandemic yeah yeah we uh we i
don't know how we got a sheba um
we randomly put our name down to a
there's a lady who does um who breed
sheba's in arizona who was living in
kyoto beforehand
right and so she moved to arizona
so she she's like super certified
everything like that she's like super
super pro and everything but we put our
name down for him and we were just like
okay like we were thinking about maybe
having a dog and then we kind of just
went out about our lives and then she
called and she went hey um
someone backed out they don't want uh
this little little guy do you want them
when we're like we're here you're that's
our boy we're here to get you i'm
already outside
i'm saying that you you spotify
listeners are like missing out right now
man yeah spotify listeners move to
youtube right now for this scene
is he your first pet he's my yeah he's
like my first dog individual i used to
have like rats and stuff when i was a
little girl in new zealand right so did
it excited everyone in new york
yeah like a little pet rat named sparky
yeah he was awesome what do you mean hi
you're not like why why why why why are
rats it's not even a mouse like a rat
yeah like rats are super smart and
clever you can teach them tricks and
they're super super like just the
sweetest little little guys
yes
he's figuring it out he's like releasing
me from the from the trash taste
i would i would love to i would love to
own a dog or just any kind of pet but
just right now as god was saying it's
the busiest year of my life right now
and i just do not have the time to take
it down i was running away yeah no i i
want to get a pet
really bad
um but i would want to settle down first
before i get it yeah but like the more
that time goes on the less i know when
i'm going to be settling down so i'm
just like the like i thought i'd be like
okay i'm going to get a pet in a year
and it went to two years yeah three
years and i'm just like i'll get a pet
someday maybe when i settle down i don't
know what one is one of these days
because like i don't want to be
traveling a lot and like being away from
home a lot when when i have a when i
have a pet i think i think we're going
to start aki and i are going to start
small so we're going to start off with
like a fish tank
yeah you know just like fish right
because like that's a rats
what do you have to do a [ __ ] rodent
why not mousy rodents
what the [ __ ] i would understand like a
mouse or like a hamster no rats are so
clever and smart i bet they are but in
your shoulder and they give you little
snuggles and kisses and they're so sweet
i think it's because like everyone's
idea of a rat is like this like a dirty
street rat yeah he said
i didn't want to do that
so
[Laughter]
what pet would you guys want if you
definitely a dog definitely a dog i
would never know what are you saying the
other day how old are she being here
yeah
the tan one or the the town one sorry
oh it's the dogecoin
version you don't want the season
really they were like you won't look
after it so you don't have it you don't
like rats you can't have it you can't
have any pets yeah if i got a rat my
parents would have been like you're gone
really yeah they don't stink or anything
so i'm such a big rat advocate i think
just the thought of having a rat in your
house it's like when you watch that tlc
of that girl like a 10 year old girl who
loves cockroaches and for some reason
the parents let her have cockroaches so
just in the room there's a bunch of
cockroaches all around her she loves it
what
what would be the negative thing of
having a cockroach well like health-wise
are they dirty would they they're not
they would breed right they
the thing was there was a bunch of them
and they were clearly around the house
so the only thing that would be bad is
just that they would be there well i
mean it's just the fact that like
there's not many people they carry like
yeah and a lot of diseases yeah yeah a
lot of diseases do they okay because i
was kind of trying to see the duality of
cockroaches yeah you know is that the
two can carry a lot of them cockroaches
in me right now
the clean one
they would they would get married and it
would be amazing because
it would just be flossed away
it would be guts and costumes and it
would be amazing you'd be like the
parent of like oh he's bringing like the
sketchy kid at home to hang out in my
house i would love that sketchy kid
because that's what parents should do
when you see the sketchy kid you go are
you okay at home i am looking to see if
you have enough in your bowl not if you
have too much bring in all the chlamydia
the black plague hasn't been around for
a long time doesn't matter i'm adopting
you
collecting the infinity stone of
diseases
i'm clearly a more patient and caring
person than myself you're british yeah
that's true i i think i think else in
europe have just been like you know
the rapture yeah yeah yeah
there's people who still get it i think
it's like i think it's like still like
it's like two or three yeah it's like
two or three people a year in the states
alone
get the black play it's me
probably you won't you wonder
so so in thailand there's actually like
a lot of like street dogs right just
like roaming around and they are like
they're just [ __ ] built different
than like even then like you know like
they're from the streets they are from
the streets right they're lit literally
right because i remember the first time
uh sydney went to thailand she was like
oh look at all the dogs look at that i
want to take care of them all and i'm
like sydney you these are the dogs you
need to be careful of right this this is
like the [ __ ] ghetto of like the dog
the dog world right now you don't you do
not want to bring [ __ ] the dog steps
up on his hind legs
like you know you [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
so like obviously like a lot of dogs
have like very sensitive stomachs you
really need to like take care of what
you feed them and everything like that
this is which is why you have like
specialized dog treats and everything
like that so i remember
uh there was like a street dog just like
outside of a combini
and
sydney like cindy felt bad so she wanted
uh she wanted to like feed it right yeah
and so what she did and i was like i was
like cindy don't do this this is a bad
idea this is this is a bad idea don't
like you know as much of a dog as much
as a of a dog even if you're a dog lover
you need to like be careful of street
dogs yeah because a lot of the times
they're under rabies as [ __ ] yeah yeah
animals in general yeah yeah yeah um so
she goes in the combination
buys like a pack of like dog food right
like dry pre-packaged dog food
she like tries to like try to like feed
feed this dog
and so she like she like pours a little
pile of of this dog food and she's like
come on come on come here come here you
must be hungry and the dog comes over
has one sniff of it and just like [ __ ]
off
he's like what the [ __ ] is this food
right
yeah i thought i was gonna bite at the
back no no no because yeah i was
expecting the dogs to be like
so that's like because like the dog then
like just goes around the corner and
like there's like some like chicken
bones on the streets and he just starts
snacking on that because because
normally you can't straight to the sauce
yeah straight to the sauce like i don't
want that processed [ __ ] i want that
free range yeah yeah yeah yeah cereal
yeah it's it's just like the dogs there
are just different and it's just so it's
kind of it's kind of it's kind of common
for like a lot of like thai houses to
have like some kind of dogs um i mean
japan's like that with cats as well
there are so many [ __ ] there are like
70 million cat islands that's what i
like what they love to call cat islands
because
so many abandoned islands especially in
the south of japan yeah are just more
cats than people now yeah and like i
went to a couple of them and yeah
they're [ __ ] cute because there's
just like cats everywhere so if you love
cats it's awesome but then you remember
they're probably infested with fleas
probably got raped yeah they from the
streets they are these these are like
street cats they're like three sharks
rabies scary it's scary
no i've seen videos people with it where
they're trying to drink water because
you've become you can't drink water like
and you know there's no cure for rabies
there's no cure you can only prevent it
from happening right
there's no there's actually like no
known cure for rabies once it actually
gets into your system i think when there
was that whole scare with like uh
in the in the dc when there's a fox that
bitten people and given them it was like
a few months ago we've given a few
rabies and a bunch of videos are going
around showing like what happens and you
get it because you physically can't
drink water yeah like what do you mean
like so you try to drink it and you're
like you spit it out because your body
is just like reject it
it's horrible yes you just get like like
iv uh yeah but a lot of people just die
you die normally quite shortly after
it's really horrible disease and it's
like one of the things you're like ah
rabies and then like when you see it
you're like oh god oh gosh yeah yeah
yeah it's [ __ ] but everyone's just
cute adam so if you see a street animal
just
admire from a distance yeah
you know i can't find it funny because
you can definitely tell like it's
sometimes froth right yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah but like you can
definitely tell like when you're walking
around in thailand sometimes like
someone takes a dog out on the walk and
you you can tell the difference between
like the domesticated and the street
dogs it's just like the the like the
domesticated dog looks over and like the
street dogs are just like yo you've come
to the wrong neighborhood man
look who's famous
look at this
that was like we were in uh we did uh we
went to tanzania to climb kilimanjaro
and then same with nepal as well we're
like it was the same thing there's like
climbed kilimanjaro yeah damn dude that
was cool oh i like how she just casually
throws it yeah just like yeah
no biggie no my mom wanted to do it so
she was she like she brought us all over
there but uh like the dogs everywhere
around there as well same thing just so
many yeah yeah but it was kind of kind
of like nice though because the dogs
there in tanzania were like you could
tell that they could just kind of like
go into people's homes and just kind of
like go hang out because they were like
like you would see when they would just
kind of like walk right into the thing
and then they were kind of like oh come
on up you know like
jumps on the stool and like in lord of
the rings because i kind of do that with
it right right
that's cool
what up why why that specifically no i
really like lord of the rings